[موسيقى]
اسرتنا
كيدي يا اغنامي يا اغنامي انطلقي بالمرج
النامي رائعه نسمات المرعى ممتد بالعشب
امامي قرات للراعي افكان ان يمرح ويدبر
مقلب يتظاهر بهجوم ذئب ان يلهو بالكذب
ويلعب النجد هاجمنا الذئب النجد اني في
ورطه يا ويلي ياكل غنماتي وعليها المتوحش
نطه هرع الناس اليه جميعا
[موسيقى]
ولمجتمع جدا هادئ والنج هنالك ترعى انا
امزح معكم اصح اصحابي حتى اريكم كم انا
بارع ولاعرف من منكم ياتي في فزع يجري
ويسارع ارتفعت ضحكات الراعي روعهم بالكذب
ويسخر غذب الناس وقالوا حتما يوما ما
بالكذب سيخسر ينجح دوما هذا المقلب والناس
تولول وتهرول لكن لا ما هذا صوت ذئب في
قربي يتجول صرخ الراعي صرخ
وصحب ي اين المنجد لكن لم يلحقه الناس
لنجدته لم ياتيه احد اهن اه يا اغنامي هذا
كان نتيجه كذبي قد ياكلني الذئب ساهرب في
حزن يتالم قلبي الناس راعي الكاذب لا يجني
خيرا يفقد ثقه الغير وايضا يتندم يبكي في
حسره يفقد ثقه الغير وايضا يتندم يبكي في
[موسيقى]
حسره